there had always been an argument that
bitcoin is a good sort of hedge against
global turmoil against central banks etc
it seems to be coming to fruition right
now so how much longer is this gonna
last
yeah institutions have spent decades
looking for non-correlated assets they
can use as a diversification their
portfolio we've been you know banging
the drum for over a year now saying that
this is a non-correlated asymmetric
asset if you look at times of global
instability like in May where we're kind
of you know lobbying tariff threats and
the trade wars are raging on bitcoins up
55% it's got a negative correlation so
is negative 0.92 SP negative point-eight
to gold and I think that we're gonna
continue to see that play out where
there's people around the world that are
electing to put their wealth into
something that is controlled by software
and cannot be manipulated by single
country or politician you know when we
see for instance in the oil markets we
see a drone strike in Iran or something
like that right you have sort of a bump
in the price of oil and that sort of a
crude premium that's built in are we
seeing a premium built into the price of
Bitcoin with this most recent rise based
on the threat of a currency war how much
does that premium do you think yeah so
we have to remember as we've seen this
play out before right in countries like
Venezuela Iran Argentina excetera where
the kursi begins to fail or there's
issues we do see large uptick in volume
where people are electing to take their
wealth out of those currencies put them
into Bitcoin there's small countries
though now we're seeing this play out in
one of the largest economies in the
world and so with 27 trillion dollars of
deposits and the Chinese banks 1% of
that moves that would double the market
capital the question I have is do you
believe that this is a true function of
outflows from China or do you think this
really is the perception of outflows
that there will be outflows from China
and therefore this is American and other
investors if you will who are pushing
the price up meaning yeah and by the way
from what I understand it's not so easy
for capital actually to live to leave
China despite the debates we've had on
this table I think is actually a
combination of both right so there are
definitely some outflows where it's
occurring you see things like and the
central bank meetings et cetera there's
reports coming out where people are
talking about Bitcoin so I definitely
think that some people are doing it at
the same time I think that what we get
is a reminder right we understand that
look why participate in the chaos right
you know what we're basically doing is
we're here to sound the alarm and say
there is a way to the opt-out there's a
way to get diversification to get a
hedge you don't go and sell all of your
assets and put a hundred percent in a
Bitcoin right but to size it in the
institutional quality portfolio of one
to five percent and be able to get that
hedge when you have non correlation when
you have these symmetric return we think
that it actually can do things to the
portfolio that other assets can't do
calling they helped me become a believer
okay because I'm a huge skeptic of this
I have like crypto crap wallet I put a
hundred dollars into it two years two
months ago at a Harvard Business School
class at night it's worth thirty dollars
and sixty two cents primarily because
all the other crap etherium XRP Bitcoin
cash like coin
stellar luminous blah blah blah blah
blah what happened to all that stuff if
this is really such a great idea why is
there only one Vegas game working yeah
well look I'll save you a lot of
headache right I'm here to talk about
Bitcoin bitcoins the most important and
I think and that's the only one that you
should you should focus on and the
reason is we are now entering a position
where it's actually irresponsible for
institutions to not have exposure to
this asset and the reason is their job
is to find assets that actually can
provide non correlation to the rest of
the markets especially in times of
global instability where there's likely
to be market draw downs Bitcoin is
providing that data it's just math right
it's not personal opinion it's not
somebody else's opinion the math
suggests that it is not correlated to
negatively correlated you dress how much
of your own dough is in it yeah over 50%
my networks in Bitcoin that I don't plan
to sell I forbid that that's insane
everything about diversification
investing that's crazy how much of your
net worth in the stock market in any one
stock never more than 5% in any one
sector never lower twenty I teach this
stuff you never go beyond concentrations
of that nature
50% shame on you that's nuts and what
but the assumption being that what
happens here for you yeah so again
because it is a scarce asset you what
you're essentially looking at is the
global adoption has to continue to occur
and it's a fixed supply it's just supply
and demand economics and I personally
believe that humans will continue to
trust software clozaril you it let's
just remember they have to
this scarcity this scarce asset there's
a lot of things that are scarce to
nobody nobody cares about course look if
you don't believe in Bitcoin you're
essentially saying you don't believe in
cryptography Anthony calling Bitcoin a
safe haven is a bit reckless in my
opinion with all the hacks you know that
a bit of Bitcoin itself the hacks are on
the exchange level which is completely
for our viewers at home who are
contemplating buying Bitcoin after
hearing you today how should they think
about safety in terms of the chain of
custody who should they open account
with trade with for sure so what we do
for our clients is we essentially use
qualified custodians they're very
similar to what you see in the legacy
system again do your own research right
to make sure that you're actually
vetting these exchanges there's a lot of
exchanges out there there's only a
couple that we actually think provide
quality solutions and we've chosen to go
with the ones that have that qualified
custodian articulation
you